from the daily wire republican governor
of utah spencer cox
signed a controversial piece of
legislation on tuesday requiring all
smartphones and tablets sold in utah to
have filters
that can block pornography governor cox
has said that the proposal would send an
important message about prohibiting
children from gaining access to explicit
online material the bill states it would
require a smartphone or tablet sold in
utah and made on or after january 1st of
the year following the year this bill
takes effect
to when activated in the state
automatically enable a filter capable of
blocking material that is harmful to
miners
the filter on the device must quote
prevent the user of the device from
accessing material that is harmful to
miners on the device enable certain
users to deactivate the filter for the
device
for specific content and notify the user
when content is filtered
um you know and that's that's the
i think yeah it's controversial
because we lived in a porn obsessed
society and
many people their porn habit is sacred
to them
and anything that can present any
obstacle
to getting to porn for a lot of people
in this country because they're addicted
to it
uh any obstacle they consider to be a
horrific affront against them and
against their
human rights because what would be the
reason for objecting to this
you want to look at porn you still look
at it it's that's not going to stop you
just you got the filter you got to
change the settings or whatever
is that too much of an effort but people
are opposed to it
the whole idea and this to me now you
know how i feel about porn i'd be in
favor of banning it out right
um so this is one little baby step in
the right direction
i'm fully in favor of it
and the point here is to protect
children and what we have to remember
is that children and i know we're
getting away from this in a big way in
society we talk about dangerous trends
a lot of dangerous trends when it comes
to race as we talked about
a lot of dangerous trends here too when
it comes to children and our ideas of
consent
but traditionally what we've always
known
and what is not just traditionally true
but actually true is that
children can't consent they don't have
this the psychological ability
to fully consent to to anything really
especially a sexual act
um looking at pornography is in effect a
sexual act
you you are you are you are becoming a
participant
a a third party participant in this
sexual act
as a viewer children can't consent to
that
they don't have the ability to consent
to it so if this stuff is made available
to them
they are victims the moment a child is
exposed to pornography
they didn't they cannot you could say
well they chose to look no they can't
choose they cannot choose to look at it
even if they choose they didn't really
choose it because they can't consent
and choices about consent they can't do
it
so we can't expect them we can't expect
children to guard
their own hearts and minds when it comes
to pornography
we have to put the filters in place to
protect them
and i don't want to hear anything about
oh it's the parent's job
if your parents should do it i agree the
parents should be doing it
that so what that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't take other steps as well
yes parents should be protecting the
kids from this but number one a lot of
parents don't
and so what are we saying about those
kids too bad
there are millions of kids in this
country their parents should be
protecting them
parents are not and so our message on
porn is well too bad so what
those kids they'll be exposed to
hardcore pornography at the age of eight
years old
and be psychologically ruined by it um
that too bad
we're not gonna do anything for them
[Music]
parents didn't help you out kid
sorry that's the attitude yeah that is
the attitude of a lot of people i find
it
i find it morally deranged
and absolutely indefensible
because the only reason you're taking
that position is just because you love
looking at porn you don't want to be
interfered with
so a lot of kids have parents who don't
protect them and then also
uh they're there it is it is not
possible
a parent can only do so much to protect
their kid from this stuff it is so
ubiquitous
and this stuff is out there everywhere
if your kid leaves your sight at all
which at a certain point he's going to
he's going to be around his friends are
going to have phones there's going to be
laptops and stuff
he's going to his friend's house he
doesn't have to go to his friend's house
anymore right
he could just go outside and be walking
with his friend the friend pulls out
the phone and looks at it like there's
only so much that you as a protective
parent can do there's a lot you can do
but you can't do everything
yet more reason to put measures in place
to to beyond what the parent can do to
help these kids
it's like the analogy that i use of um
you know think about buying pornography
the old-fashioned way
the way they used to do it in the old
days going to a you know the gas station
buying a porn magazine or something now
um what if a kid
went in you know 10 year old kid goes
into a gas station pulls a porn mag off
of the rack
um and goes to buy it
it would be illegal for the cashier to
sell that magazine
to the child now you can say what's that
kid doing at a gas station by himself
where are that kid's parents
it's the parent's job to make sure the
kid's not buying a porn mag
true you're right yes but
for whatever reason the parents aren't
there right now um the kid is there
so does that mean that the cashier
should just sell it to him
the fact that the parent isn't there is
that an excuse is that a good reason
is that justification for the cashier to
make the decision to sell that magazine
i would hope you would say no
even if this kid has neglect neglectful
or negligent parents
especially if he has negligent parents
still you can't sell in the magazine
you're committing a crime if you do
see you as the gas station the person at
the gas station
selling this material the onus is on you
to put measures in place to make sure
that kids are not obtaining this stuff
you you can't do everything either there
are ways around it for kid but
there are some basic measures we expect
you
to put in place as the person who is
offering this stuff
to protect kids why don't we have the
same requirements of porn sites
we have zero request you understand that
zero
right now there are zero requirements
for porn sites
in terms of um
of protecting kids and making sure that
they're not giving their product to
children
they zero we don't expect anything of
them
we expect more of the cashier at the gas
station
than we do of like pornhub
once again indefensible makes no sense
at all and i i've never heard a defense
for this
other than i've heard a lot of defenses
but they all seem to boil down to
the person saying it what they're really
saying is i like porn and you know
i i i don't want to think about it
anymore than that and i don't want
anything to interfere with me looking at
one
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content